okay I've said it before and I stand by
it when Donald Trump does something
progressive should like then we should
support it Donald Trump has officially
signed an executive order withdrawing
the United States from the trans-pacific
partnership he promised to do this
during the campaign and he did it TPP
was a disaster it was hugely
pro-corporate it expanded copyright and
patent law for corporations it created
this transnational arbitration
infrastructure so that big corporations
could in many ways skirt the laws of
individual countries they operate in and
instead be subject to arbitration in
this transnational tribunal etc etc
disaster okay but PPP has been dead for
months the real story here is that US
involvement in TPP has been dead at
least since November 15th when both
Democrat Chuck Schumer and Republican
Mitch McConnell said this isn't going to
pass Congress hadn't approved TPP under
Obama there was every indication the
u.s. wasn't going to approve TPP even if
you don't believe our Hillary Clinton in
the end said numerous times she was
against TPP Trump's fulfilled a campaign
promise on paper and for that I say good
job pat but this wasn't happening TPP
was dead yeah if you want to give Trump
credit on this I guess you can Hillary
Clinton probably would have done the
same thing too and as you said it was
dead on arrival but I think it's really
just a victory for the American worker
and for the public because if there's
enough backlash against trade deals like
this and people and things that people
don't really want tore up people in
Congress will not adhere to their donors
as much and go back to the people like I
want and I want to even go further it's
because of the public outcry against TPP
but partially it was basically dead on
arrival and we heard from both Democrats
and Republicans and positions of power
on November 15 that it wasn't happening
so if you want to say I'm not giving
Trump credit where credit is due no I'm
giving Trump credit for following
sticking to a campaign promise in that
he would sign off on withdrawing from
TPP what I'm not getting from credit for
is stopping the u.s. from actually being
involved in PPP because that's been a
foregone conclusion for many months the
bigger news from the same Oval Office
signing ceremony is
not making as much news and I'm going to
delve into it on tomorrow's show which
is that Trump is imposed a federal
hiring freeze to supposedly save money
federal hiring freezes cost us money and
I'll explain why tomorrow and that's not
really making nearly as much headlines
okay send me your thoughts on this after
the break the first part of my interview
with all right leader white nationalist
Richard Spencer who got punched in the
face twice at a trump inauguration of a
weekend event that's starting right
after the break stay with us gamefly is
sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low use price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer calm / tdps the games are shipped
directly to you would return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s